How is everyone doing today?
All right!
Sweet.
Hello!
My name is Steve.
As
we've probably gathered.
And I am an instructor at the Turing School
of
Software and Design out in Colorado.
What is that?
It's a 7 month developer
training program where we take people who
don't know how to develop web
applications and hopefully show them how to
develop web applications over the
course of that 7 months.
So if you're interested in mentoring people
who want
to become developers, please come talk to
me.
If you would like to hire six,
seven, 12 developers, also come talk to me.
I've got cards and other fun
stuff.
Other administrivia -- we're starting a nodebots
group in Colorado.
So
if you are in the Boulder region, come hang
out with us.
Everything you can
see today lives in a little readme file on
this repo.
So you can play along.
If you start playing with it while I'm talking,
this is an audio talk, and
I'll know -- so maybe wait until lunchtime.
But everything is there along with
the slides and everything else.
So as you've probably gathered from the title
of this talk, either A you're in the wrong
room or B you're here to hear about
making music with a web browser.
So I have a little secret for you.
I'll just
get this out of the way now.
As it turns out, somebody put a synthesizer
into your web browser.
It's true.
So what does that mean?
It takes the form of this fun thing called
the Web
Audio API, which Sam just kind of introduced
us to a little bit, and I'm going
to go into a little more detail with.
And how do we use this Web Audio API?
That's a great question and I'm glad that
you asked it.
Start with some
context.
So if you've ever worked with HTML5 canvas
or anything along those
lines, you're familiar with a context.
It's the canvas you're drawing on.
In
this case, it's the audio graph that you're
working with.
In most cases, there
is one audio context per page.
Basically you create one, spin it up, and
start
to hook together your different audio nodes.
How do we do that?
That's a good
question as well.
Basically there's a built-in in the browser
called audio
context, there's a little bit of vendor prefix
silliness going on with Safari.
So in order to support Safari, we do this
little trick -- oh, hey, give me
your audio context.
You don't have that?
I'll take your Webkit audio context.
Either way.
We'll do Tomfoolery to get it.
And then we have it to use.
So what
is a web audio context?
We need to get the audio out of our browser.
So we
have this thing called a destination.
The metaphor I'm going to use if you've
ever played guitar is -- it's like your amplifier.
The thing you're plugging
everything into.
Technically speaking, the operating system's
audio, whatever.
It's the amplifier.
Your computer speakers, your ear buds, whatever.
We also
need some kind of sound source.
And we connect that sound source to our
destination and we can make sound.
The other cool thing is we can put a whole
bunch of stuff in the middle, like
effect pedals.
If you were playing guitar, a wa-wa pedal
or delay or chord
pedal.
Take the nodes, whatever sources, do the processing
on it, and send
that processed version of our audio to the
destination and get to use it as
well.
So let's start by talking about the first
piece of this.
We want to get
some sound out of the browser, so we're going
to need to set up that audio
context destination.
And that is also pretty easy to do.
That context that we
created in the last little code sample -- it's
got a bunch of properties and
methods on it.
One of those is destination, and that is a
representation of
your audio context destination.
It is your amplifier.
It's what you're going
to plug other stuff into and where sound is
going to come out.
So we've got a
destination.
And now we need some kind of audio source.
And we've got a bunch of options.
We could load in some kind of sound file.
That would be cool.
We could take
something from the user's microphone and analyze
it and process it along those
lines.
Or we could generate our own tones.
Now, we're talking about making
music with the browser.
Right?
So the first two are kind of off the table.
We
don't want to take a pre-recorded music and
play it.
That's been done.
Right?
Midi files in the '90s.
On my Geocities page.
I'm not embarrassed at all.
We
don't just want to play recorded sounds.
We want to make sounds.
So our hero
is going to be the oscillator, which you got
a bit of an introduction to in
the last talk.
And an oscillator basically creates a sound
wave.
And a sound wave is just kind of vibration
in the air that your ear makes some
sense out of, and turns into a given tone,
and there's some distance between
each of the waves and the amplitude, which
is how high the peaks are and how
deep the valleys are.
Right?
Which...
For our purposes, is basically the
volume.
How do we create an oscillator?
Again, we've got some methods on that
context that we created before.
And all we have to do is call create
oscillator, and we have created an oscillator.
And that's great.
Now we've got
an oscillator and a destination.
Next we need to connect the two of them.
Take
our keytar in this case and plug it into our
amp to get any sound out of it.
So we've got a method on that oscillator and
we connect the method to the
context destination.
So we plug the keytar into the amp and we're
almost ready
to rock and roll.
Because the other thing is we need to hit
some keys on the
keytar in order to play anything.
So we start our oscillator and have it
create some sounds for us.
How do we start an oscillator?
We call start on it.
You might be wondering...
What is this zero?
That is when you want it to
start.
How far in the future you want it to start.
In this case, we want it to
start right now.
Firefox and Chrome -- totally okay with you
omitting this.
It
will just start immediately.
Safari, not okay with this.
So we put in a zero,
say -- I want to start this oscillator and
start it right now.
And that's great.
You probably messed up your frequency.
If you're like me,
you're blowing out your eardrums right now
with a super high pitched
frequency.
Now you probably want to stop it.
Surprise -- the method is called
stop.
Here's where it gets tricky.
All right.
I'm done blowing out my ear
drums.
I want to adjust the frequency and I want
to start the oscillator
again.
Not going to happen.
Right?
Here's the kind of gotcha on that.
Once you
stop an oscillator, you cannot restart it.
Game over.
You have to get rid of
it.
And get a new one.
So you might say to yourself...
All right.
Yeah.
I'll
just generate another one.
No big deal.
The other thing you want to make sure
that you do is disconnect the oscillator that
you had, so it can get garbage
collected.
If you don't disconnect it, the context still
has a reference to
it, it starts hanging out in memory, you get
out of control, do that too much,
congratulations -- you have a memory leak.
Don't have a memory leak.
Disconnect your oscillators when you're done.
It's the responsible thing to
do.
So now it's gotten garbage collected.
We can bring in a new one.
And here
it is.
The other thing we talked about before is
that we can connect stuff in the
middle.
So you might say -- I don't want to keep creating
and destroying
oscillators.
That seems reckless.
I'm not interested in doing that.
It's
actually pretty efficient.
It's not a big deal.
But...
It makes me feel a
little dirty.
So the other option is to plug in our sound
source, into some
kind of intermediary node, that will process
that sound, and in this case, we
use a gain node, where we can basically turn
up and down the amplitude, which
for our purposes is the volume.
So we can turn the volume down to zero and
yeah, the oscillator is still running, but
none of the sound is getting to the
destination, which means for all intents and
purposes the thing is stopped.
That's it.
And when we're ready to hear from it again,
we can turn the gain up
to one, which is the default setting, and
all of the sound will continue to
travel through.
So we kind of get to mimic the idea that we're
turning the
oscillator on and off, but really we're just
adjusting an intermediary gain
node instead.
How do we do that?
There should be no surprises here.
Context has a few other
methods for generating the intermediary nodes
we might need.
In this case, we
create a gain node, and we can hook up our
keytar to our gain node, connect
the oscillator to the gain node, then hook
the gain node up to our
destination.
And now we can start the oscillator, and we
can just adjust the
volume.
To kind of give the illusion that we're turning
it off and on but in
fact, we're just simply adjusting again an
intermediary node.
So again, we
notice that we're talking about the oscillator.
The oscillator has a bunch of
other properties to it.
What frequency?
What should be the bandwidth of those
waves?
Right?
How close together or far apart should they
be?
By default, we
get an oscillator that is at 440.
But we can adjust it down to 220, adjust it
up to 8,000.
Don't do that if you're wearing headphones,
again.
I don't know
if you...
There was a...
Malls in the UK a few years ago would play
super high
pitched tones, because as you get older, you
can't hear those, so it would be
for the sole purpose of scaring away teenagers.
So there's a use for this, in
your practical everyday life.
When you want teenagers to go away, create
an
ultrahigh frequency and turn it on.
It might also scare away your dog and cat.
That could be a bonus, depending on how you're
feeling about them at the
moment.
So this is the shape of the wave.
We get a few out of the box by
default.
A sine wave is this curvy happy wave, sounds
pretty pleasant to the
ears.
A square wave gets its name from looking like
squares, a triangle wave
gets its name from looking like triangles,
and a saw tooth looks like a saw.
Not a lot of heavy vocabulary here.
It's like hey, that's what that wave looks
like.
And if you want, you can also create your
own custom wave forms that are
different from those, but those are the default
traditional synthesizer sound
waves that we've had available since the '70s.
And we can basically --
oscillator has a property on it, where we
can change it to whatever type of
wave that we want.
So let's actually take a look at this.
We're going to look
at a little example, where we can kind of
create an oscillator.
There we go.
I
can adjust the gain here.
(pure tone playing)
So this is a sine wave, and we can change
the frequency...
(higher pure tone playing)
And you can see as the frequency increases,
then in that case the pitch to
our ears sounds higher.
We can also...
I'm going to go back down to 220 for
everyone's benefit.
Because I care.
(lower pure tone playing)
We can try a square wave.
(noisier tone playing)
And the triangle.
So the shape of the wave has different tonal
properties
to our ears.
And we can change it.
For the rest of this talk, we're going to
be going with the nice sine wave, because
it's probably the most pleasant.
Cool!
So at this point, we now know how to make
sound!
And that's super cool.
Sound is necessary, but it's not sufficient
for making music.
Right?
So it's
called the Web Audio API, not the web music
API.
It's going to help make some
sound, but it's on us to turn that sound into
music.
We're going to need to
know a few things about music in order to
get this working.
So we talked a little bit about the default
frequency of an oscillator.
It's
440.
If you've ever seen one of those tuning forks,
that A4, and it's what we
base most of our general tones -- on most
Western musical instruments.
So
we've got 440.
If we were to double that frequency to 880,
conveniently, we
would get A5.
Which is an A note, but an octave higher.
And if we were to
halve 440 to that 220 we had before, we would
have A, but an octave lower.
I
don't know if you know this, but there are
more notes than just A.
We have
semi-tones -- and the 12 units in between
two octaves.
That's simply a Western
music thing.
It's not like a physics law or anything, but
we have decided that
these are the tones that sound reasonably
pleasant to our ears.
And some of
them have some basis in actual physics.
If you take a guitar string and put
your finger in the middle of the string, that
is usually one octave higher.
If
you put it a third of the way, you'll get
a fifth, and so on and so forth.
So
we've got basic ones and we filled in the
gaps.
So if you want to get the rest
of the notes, you might say to yourself -- I'll
using math.
That's reasonable.
At first glance it works.
A at 440, A an octave up, it's 880, and if
we divide
by 1/12 steps each way, we get there.
No big deal.
Sounds great.
Unfortunately, it only works in one key.
Right?
If you were to start at C, you
can see almost immediately the notes don't
match up.
So if you were to use
this kind of mathematical approach, you could
create an instrument that only
sounds good in one key.
And that's -- it's called a harmonica.
Right?
You buy
a whole bunch of them, and you never learn
how to play them.
And that's kind
of how it works.
But...
So the first thing I tried to do is like -- all
right.
I'm smart.
Reasonably.
I can figure this out.
So I'll come up with an
algorithm that will, like, work.
Unfortunately, this is a problem that humans
have been working on for thousands of years,
and I was not able to figure out
on one Red Bull-fueled afternoon.
However, it occurred to me that...
You know
what I'll do?
I'll just steal an approach that already works.
We have figured
this out.
This is a solved problem.
Going by units of 1/12 is equal
temperament.
The other approach is to use this thing called
just intonation,
which is a bunch of compromises between the
other keys.
So it's not perfect in
a physical sense, in the way of equal temperament,
but it is reasonably good
in every key, but not perfectly accurate in
any of them.
So we can steal
something from the piano.
I just needed a way to get from the piano
frequencies and just steal a little cheat
sheet from that, and be able to use
this.
I was just keeping a giant hash table in a
file and trying to reference
it.
It was getting obnoxious.
So when you have a need and a cute name for
a
project, you have an Open Source library.
A little library called Octavian,
and basically what it does -- you can hand
it a general note and what it'll do
is give you the frequency.
Also give you all those other things you might
need
to use, like what key on the piano it is.
All it basically does is reference a
lookup table of this note on the piano, this
would be this frequency.
The
other fun thing it does is it lets you do
the different intervals between
notes.
A major chord is a root note, major third,
and perfect fifth.
A minor
chord is a root note, a minor third, and a
perfect fifth.
So you can reason
about these notes and get everything you need
along the way.
All right.
So now we can create sound.
And the other thing we can do is we can
reason about it, in terms of music.
Let's actually build a musical instrument.
So this is a little example instrument called
audiophonic.
And let's take a
look.
Adam?
Adam is going...
Ladies and gentlemen, Adam Sontag is going
to
play us a song.
(applause)
All right.
You ready?
So... (inaudible)
(playing happy pure tones up and down)
Really hard without looking.
Yeah.
(inaudible)
(playing boogie-woogie-style improvisation)
(laughter)
Round of applause for Adam!
More like AJ's synthesizer.
So as you can see,
we can hover over a bunch of notes and it
will play tones and if we press a
key, it will activate that tone.
So we've created a musical instrument.
That's
great.
How exactly did we do that?
So the trick here is we basically spun up
a
bunch of oscillators, and hooked them all
up to gain nodes, and on different
events, we'll simply turn one of those on
and off.
So when a key gets pressed,
it will listen for a key down event.
When that key down event happens, what
we'll do is we'll say -- all right.
I have this synthesizer object.
Get me an
oscillator for C3.
And it will go ahead and look up -- do I have
one?
In this
notes hash?
No.
If I don't have one...
What it'll do is go and put one in
there for me.
There we are.
I'm caught up.
And then return it out.
Now, a real synthesizer usually has, like,
three oscillators that it's
adjusting the frequencies on and turning it
on and off.
But I've got 16 gigs
of RAM and I'm going to treat myself to 80
oscillators.
I can do that.
If I
have one, great.
If I don't, make one, put it in the table,
and use it as
well.
What is this oscillator thing?
It's a little abstraction.
It creates an
oscillator and a gain node, sets some default
values on them, in this case the
frequency I want an oscillator for, hook them
up together, start it, return it
out to me, and I've got start and stop methods
that are not actually start and
stop methods on the oscillator but on the
gain node.
For me, I feel like I'm
working on the oscillator, but there's a few
more things happening in the
middle.
So if we hit the button bound to C3, get me
an oscillator for C3,
start it, and when they do a key up event,
we'll simply send it off and we'll
stop the oscillator.
And that's all we need to do, to create a
very small
synthesizer.
Nothing like saying that in front of 600 people.
So that's cool!
But that's only, like, why wouldn't you just
buy a keyboard at
that point?
Why do you need to do all this?
It's fun.
You can share with your
friends and they can use it, and it's great
to come up on stage and play in
front of everyone.
That's awesome.
But why would we want to use something like
it?
The other kind of interesting part is that
somebody put a web browser in
your synthesizer.
That's not the only API that's available in
the browser.
So
the fun comes in when we start mixing and
matching different APIs.
So one
example is -- we can mix the Web Audio API
with the get user media API.
My
favorite slide coming up.
So this little app called face theremin.
Are you
familiar with what a theremin is?
The thing that makes the spooky space music
and you lift your hand and everything.
So I thought it would be cool if I
could do that with my face.
So what we'll do...
I can't actually see myself
here.
(theremin swooping up and down)
(applause)
In fairness, most of the hard work there is
being done by the head tracking
software.
So it detects your face.
And when you move your face, it emits a
face tracking event.
Right?
Which has a whole bunch of properties on it.
I
really only care about two of them right now.
You might care about other ones.
But height and the X value to -- the X is
the horizontal, where am I in this
direction or that direction, and the height
is how close or how far I am, and
I'll take those two properties and do some
simple math to make sure they're
reasonable frequencies and gain amounts, and
then I'll take my oscillator and
my gain value and I'll adjust them accordingly.
And that's really all there is
to it.
There's also the entire face tracking library,
but that's somebody
else's problem.
And then lastly, I will bind myself to that
event, and update stuff along
those lines.
Okay.
So now we've seen the real power here is when
we can mix
and match other APIs.
What about web sockets?
All right.
So you might say --
cool!
We can have an instrument where a bunch of
people can play in realtime
together.
There is some latency.
So you don't want a bunch of people moving
their heads together, synchronized head movements.
Or even playing keyboard
tones.
Because there's going to be some latency,
and the other part about
music that I never had was rhythm.
So that's going to be an issue with the
latency thing.
But we can kind of address that by using what's
called a step
sequencer.
We've got 16 quarter notes, which I have zero
indexed, because this
is a JavaScript conference, and they are quarter
notes and we'll step through
each and every one of those, and then the
rows are a bunch of musical notes.
In this case, I have only chosen C, D, G,
and A, because it's very difficult
for you to make a melody that sounds bad with
that.
You could probably do it.
I believe in you.
But it makes it like...
When you have multiple people
playing...
So now what we can do is -- any time somebody
activates a square on
the grid, we send that over web sockets to
a little express socket IO server.
That will then take that sequence, match it
up with all the other ones it has,
and push it out to all the other connected
clients.
And what we'll do then is when it gets to
the client, we'll take all the
sequences, and we'll -- for the user sequence,
we'll, like, make those bright
yellow.
For everyone else, we'll make them this pale
color.
Render all the
other sequences below.
But we'll then combine them all to one sequence
that
will get played out.
So it'll be everyone's music together.
Let's take it for
a spin.
Beep!
Excellent.
Now you know what's coming next.
There's my face
again.
All right.
So here we've got a sequencer, and I happen
to have an iPad
over here, to be my other set of ears.
So I can begin to unmute.
And I'll
start playing like a bass line.
This is so hard!
I can't see.
(bass line playing perfect fifths up and down)
All right.
So I've got a bass line going.
So I can start playing a melody
here.
(top line with distortion playing melody)
There's the sequence I'm playing on the iPad.
Here's the bass line that I
put down in my browser.
And they're all being connected.
Ideally, you could
have tens, twenties, hundreds of people creating
music together as well.
And
there's a link to this in the repo that I
posted, so I totally encourage you
at lunch to have a giant JSConf song.
It's only going to be four measures long
and made out of four different notes, but
whatever!
Mute!
All right.
(applause)
So...
That's cool.
But so far we've also been a little bit limited
by what
we've been able to do on the screen.
So we've kind of had to either bind stuff
to the keyboard, which is kind of cool but
also kind of difficult, because
it's not a musical instrument.
Or we've been able to click on different
things.
As we know, JavaScript runs on the client.
It runs on the server.
It
also runs on hardware.
Which means we can begin to build our own
musical
instruments.
Right?
I've got a very small example we're going
to switch to in
a moment.
But it means you can build, like, a Nintendo
Power Glove.
There's an
'80s reference, by the way.
Where every pinch of the finger started to
play a
different note.
It means you can use all the sensors that's
available for
Arduino, and begin to create hardware musical
instruments programmed in
JavaScript that work with the Web Audio API
in the browser.
So this is a
really clear diagram of what I've got going
on here.
And I'll explain this.
But basically we've got some buttons, and
we've got a little potentiometer.
And whenever we hit one of the buttons, it'll
send a signal to Johnny5.
Johnny5 has an express and socket IO server
running alongside of it, which is
incredibly easy to do, by the way, and it
will send that data over the web
socket to the browser, and the browser will
start playing that tone, based on
the button that we hit.
So I'm going to listen for pins 2, 4, 6, and
8.
I'm
just going to keep them in this quick little
object over here.
I'm going to
say -- when the button is down, we'll send
whatever key that was, whatever
button that was, and we'll send that as true.
When the button is up, we'll
send one saying it's false.
Basically the status of the buttons on my
board --
I'm sending them out to the browser.
And then the potentiometer is, as we turn
it, going to go through all the
notes between C3 and C5.
So let's check out the demo.
(notes playing arpeggio)
(top pure tones playing thirds up and down)
(lower distorted tones echoing)
(rapid repeated notes on top line)
(major chords on distorted bottom line)
Cool!
So basically at this point...
Not only can we build our own hardware
that creates music in the browser with JavaScript
-- there's very limitless
possibilities.
And so the moral of the story is that music
is pretty awesome!
I think we can all agree on that.
The web -- also pretty awesome.
Music and
the web together are like ice cream and cookie
dough.
Each individually
awesome, but exponentially more awesome when
put together.
And we only kind of
scratched the surface.
There's a bunch of other really cool APIs.
There's the
gamepad API, there is web RTC, so you could
theoretically create multi-face
theremin.
There is the gyroscope accelerometer API,
and there is also mixing
and matching the possibilities we went over.
So limitless possibilities for
you to create musical instruments that have
never existed before.
So I kind of
encourage you to do that.
On the page, it has the links to everything.
Whee!
If you make something
really cool, please send me a pull request,
and we'll put a link below, and
let's, like, collect all the really cool musical
instruments that you make in
the next days, weeks, and months.
And with that...
Thank you very much.